- Hi it's Liza Treyger.
I can not stop smiling
because I'm at the AVN Awards in Vegas!
I tricked Comedy Central into letting me
do red carpet interviews.
I have zero experience but I'm here.
We'll ask questions and meet
the biggest names in porn.
Well this is my first AVN,
do you have any advice?
- Ooh, yeah.
Pace yourself 'cause it's
gonna keep getting more wild.
- Hydrate. Hydrate, hydrate.
- Hydrate for the road.
I've just keep drinking whiskey.
- Just keep it mellow.
- Does that mean like smoke weed?
- If that's what helps.
- What advice do you have
for me? It's my first AVNs.
- Learn to gag.
- Can you give me a porn name?
- Give you a porn name?
- Yeah.
- Candy Tits.
- Pretty Titties.
- Betty Bad Ass.
- Yes.
- Cream Soda.
- Lyza Big Titty.
I see you and I see, like Gina Valentina.
- That's so nice.
- Like because it's such a sweet name.
- You already have a porn star name,
you got a Z in your name.
That's already sexy cause
X and Z are like, you know,
are worth like 10 points in Scrabble.
- What's the biggest lie in porn?
- That I'm a raging bitch?
No that's actually true, fuck.
- What's the biggest secret in porn?
- The biggest secret in porn?
- Squirt's not real.
- But I squirt and I feel like it's real,
I'm not trying too hard.
- Okay let me say porn squirt
(chuckling) is not real.
Sorry
- Squirt is Pee.
- I'm squirting!
- What's the biggest kept secret in porn?
- We use like sponges in our vagina
when we have our period
so we can still fuck.
- That's a very good secret,
thank you for sharing that.
- Girls poop on you a lot.
Really pretty girls will
poop on you all the time.
- Like cream pie spills
usually aren't real.
- What is real?
Is it a different substance in them?
- Yeah usually they use um...
- Cetaphil.
- Thank you.
Cetaphil, thank you.
- If you could make
your bodily fluids taste
like anything, what flavor would they be?
- Steak.
- Steak?
- Yeah sure, why not?
- Alright.
- Probably a ribeye, I like ribeyes.
- Ribeye jizz, okay.
- Scotch.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- That was not the answer I was expecting.
- What did you think she was gonna say?
- Passion fruit.
- Oh also good, also good.
- You know every bitch
goes, "Oh I eat pineapple,
"I drink pineapple juice,"
their (bleep) still taste disgusting.
- Do you ever masturbate
to your own movies?
- No, hell no.
- Only the scenes where I like
know that I came really good.
- All the time.
- Really?
- Literally like twice a week.
- When I watch myself I'm like,
"Oh I don't know why
I'm making that face."
- No, I hate my own voice.
- Absolutely, all the time.
- Yeah?
- My first anal just got released
and I'm kinda diggin' that
cause it's the only
time I can watch myself
get (bleep) in the (bleep).
- What's something that
you haven't filmed,
that you wanna film?
- You know I have not filmed
an official gang bang.
- Getting gang banged.
- Gang bang.
- Like a gang bang but like,
I'm the only one banging.
- Is there something that
you haven't filmed yet
that you're dying to film?
- Anal.
- A Bukkake.
- You've never done that?
- No.
- I would really like to
film a scene in zero gravity.
- Alright?
What was your last Google search?
- Soil fertility.
- Amazing, what are you planting?
- Nothing.
- That's a wrap from the AVN red carpet.
I've had a dream night
and I found my friends
for the night, so I am out of here.
Bye.